I couldn't sleep that night I remember
thinking I'm all alone then I realized I
had nothing to hide there you are
I just decided I wasn't gonna be afraid
[Music]
when they assigned her to me was my idea
to send her to Iran get her into the
nuclear division her cover an English
and French teacher I probably not gonna
sleep tonight I'm gonna do brain you're
the best person for this assignment did
you know she was breaking she had no
idea great so what do you do
haven't you learned not to ask questions
like that the people here all have many
secrets you're gonna tell me what's
going on she disappeared disappeared she
could be anywhere now you couldn't
control her she wanted to make that
point there's much more going on I'll
handler I don't think you should get
into this
need to find a way to bring him here
what is going on you wouldn't understand
follow your protocols assuming you know
everything but you don't this is war and
in war
people Donna
[Music]
are you pulling me out not
[Music]
you